[Music]
all right let's go to caroline
in dallas texas caroline what's going on
is it caroline or carolyn carolyn it's
carol lynn
i screwed it up sorry all right carol
hey so what's going on how are you i'm
good
um awesome talking about my question is
there's tons of layers
to it but my main question is i have a
young adult son who recently moved out
i think he's rebelling and so the
control that i perceived i had is lost
and i want to support him but i don't
want to
enable him awesome so give me some more
contacts how old is this adult son
he just turned 19. 19. all right
is he in school is he working does he do
anything
he's not we recently moved here from new
mexico and he had started culinary
school here but one day he came home and
decided that
he was done he was moving back to new
mexico with friends there wasn't
anything we could do about it there
wasn't really much of a conversation and
that was that
okay this is he back in new mexico he is
okay
have you been able to breathe yet
um some days um i've
he's living with a friend and a friend's
mom
and i'm just struggling because there's
no accountability
or um there's no
he doesn't have any responsibility to
contribute to the household or take it a
job or to move forward in life and i
think that's what i'm struggling with
the most is that here he had that
and he went to a place purposefully i
believe that he doesn't have that
yeah so you back to what your original
statement is
it sucks when you find out you don't
have any control doesn't it
yes and from listening to another
podcast he was that adhd boy that i
he had lots of chaos in young life i had
him as a teenager
um i had another partner didn't work out
but he was really close too and then i
have the husband who i have now who's
wonderful but he was four and headlocks
before that and so we tried all the
things that you mentioned
taking things away doing all these
things but i think the connection wasn't
there and i didn't realize that until it
was
too late so here's what i want to
challenge you with
never say the words too late with your
son okay
okay right now you're in a season and
he's 19 he's going to flex
in so be it
if he would be willing to one day meet
you in lubbock somewhere or meet you out
in
portals or clovis somewhere and you all
have dinner
and just say hey you're you're a grown
adult guy
and i love you and you're gonna do what
you're gonna do i want you to know you
always got a place at our house
and i'm not going to give you money but
i love you
and i wish you the absolute best
and i wanted him to have that connection
with you
and this is going to sound ridiculous
and silly
but i'm hearing more and more and more
the value of this
as people write in from all across the
country and i've had this experience in
my own life
i want you to begin writing in letters
and here's why um you may have heard me
say this before
it's something he can hold on to and his
19 year old brain is looking for every
reason to justify why he just
bailed on you guys and is doing nothing
in some burnouts house in new mexico and
if he gets a letter from you even a
short one
once a week number one it helps you
because you're writing about him it's
really a form of journaling for you
but he's gonna hold in his hand there's
no way he can misconstrue
this or twist this it's going to say hey
hope you're doing so well this funny
thing happened
we miss you around here we love you and
we hope you're doing great
no you should be doing none of that
because he knows he knows that stuff
right and he's not going to do it and
you harp it on him isn't going to help
um if he chooses to ever come back with
you of course you can have boundaries
there he's going to be held accountable
and all that kind of stuff
my guess is there's gonna come a moment
when he calls you for money
and instead of giving him money i want
you to get him a plane ticket home
and give him a bed to sleep in and then
y'all can begin to
to reconnect there okay but i wouldn't
say
like he's resenting us
for things that he says are i mean um
the person he's living with has
very different views than us obviously
and so he's resenting us
and speaking those things but we're also
like paying his entrance and we've told
him that that's ending
because now he's grown up and moved out
and so but
i'm not i've not ever been good at
holding to that like when the
deadline came i would say well you can
do this instead
or i'll extend it for this or you know
what i mean but i know i've got to hold
them accountable but i know that that's
going to put
more distance between us because he's
going to be mad that i'm not just
letting him
drive around with my car with my
insurance right does he have your car
well he has a truck that we bought for
him but it's in our name and then we
his insurance is on our policy so what i
would do is let him know hey i'm going
to sell you the truck
and even if y'all choose to sell it for
500 right well below
but he needs to have some skin in that
game say it's in our name we got to get
it off our name
um or you can say hey we bought this for
you this is yours
um we're going to sell it to you for one
dollar so that we can
change the title over and he's got to do
that or you're going to file
stolen truck charges in 60 days and then
you're going to get off your insurance
and i'd give him a landing page
or i mean a landing space don't just say
i'm to cut it off tomorrow
but you can tell them you know in 30
days and 60 days you're gonna be on your
own there
and we love you love you love you and we
wish you the best
i don't have a problem um i resented my
parents at 19
right i don't know a lot of kids that
don't or go through some sort of
yeah they just that's the part of
growing up the challenge for parents is
to not take it personally
and not compromise what you believe in
your values
to try to make him like you right you're
playing a long game with him right now
and so your goal now is to hold your
values but also stay connected to that
relationship
and he's got to learn yeah you can't
just pack up your mom and dad's stuff
and take off
and have them still fund your life
that's cool man but i love your attitude
if you can keep up even if you have to
hold it together and you hang up the
phone and you cry your eyes out
staying positive when you talk to him on
the phone hey man
um we're gonna go ahead and sign that
truck over to your name but you're gonna
have to buy it from us for ten dollars
or a hundred dollars or ten thousand
whatever you all think
um okay and we're gonna take you off the
insurance
because you're an adult now he can say
all the resentful things he wants that's
why i want you to continue to pipe into
him once a week
for the next five years 10 years 20
years one year
we love you hope you're doing so great
let us know how you're doing
and um but he can't delete those things
he can throw in the trash if he wants to
but it's different than electronic
communication it's something he can hold
in his hands
right and um invite him home for
holidays if you if he wants to
and man let him have his political views
let him have his whatever
who cares about all that stuff that's
your son right um
but if he wants to move out he can move
out
okay is there ever a point though that i
i mean because he's not going around
good places he's not going around good
people
um and that's been confirmed so like i
deleted it now because i know you're
telling too but i had gps for a while
and
the place says he's going in the middle
of the night are not good or healthy or
safe like
in his biological dads and addicts
though that i'm hyper
fearful of that um you're coming home
yeah he's a grown man
control's over yeah i'm struggling with
really realizing that
yeah and you've been through this before
right his birth dad broke your heart
and his birth dad's heart was broken too
you see this you see what's what's down
the the
track for your son the only chance
you've got
is not a power play because you can't do
anything about it
the power of the only chance you've got
is connection here
and addiction is a connection issue
right
that's it and whether that's a daily
text or a weekly text and a weekly
letter whatever it is man that's what
you've got
and you're gonna torture yourself by
tracking him in the middle of the night
absolutely torture yourself and you're
not gonna do any better for him
you'll it's like ruminating right you
feel like it's good thinking it's not
right you're just choosing to drown
yourself and this is when you back up
and you really double down on your
relationship with your husband
you all begin to it would probably be
good for you guys to go see somebody
because this is going to bring up
years of grieving that you may or may
not have done
about old relationships about old i wish
i should have
all those kind of things with your son
you are going to have to have a plan
together you and your husband for moving
forward
and so man heartbreaking but you said it
when you called you're struggling with
this realization that you got no control
you're right it's hard
sucks it's heartbreaking and i hate it
for you
hate it for you
[Music]
i'll hate it for you double down on
connection
you make sure that you be the adult and
you always reach out reach out reach out
stop funding the lifestyle he's a grown
man he's made grown man decisions he can
make
um he can have grown-up consequences
and the only chance you've got is
connection you know what i'm gonna
i i said maybe you 100 should
you're going to struggle with guilt
you're going to struggle with what did i
do
it's going to impact your current
relationship i think it's really
important for you to go find
a local counselor there in dallas and
both for you and your relationship your
marriage and make sure you all are
connecting and you're healing
as this goes on it's going to be hard